ever since it hit theaters in August
2017 Annabel creation is scared the
pants off millions of fans and finally
revealed just where that demonic doll
from the conjuring that really came from
but if this horror origins story left
with more questions and answers don't be
afraid we've got everything you need to
know about the film's ending and
post-credit scenes unless you don't want
to see spoilers for the conjuring and
both Annabelle films in which case that
this is your cue to cover your eyes and
hide under the covers until the video is
over the doll is just a vessel Annabelle
might be inherently creepy but before
she became infested by an evil spirits
she was just a very expensive
handcrafted doll and the part where she
has a face like something out of a
nightmare an unfortunate coincidence the
origin of Annabelle XIV all comes when
the Mullins invite the spirit of their
deceased daughter to live inside the
doll only to realize that the entity in
that porcelain body isn't a human ghost
at all but something ancient powerful
and extraordinarily evil with the help
of some Catholic priests Samuel Mullins
manages to trap the doll in the closet
lines of Scripture and he hopes that'll
be the end of it but while Scripture
might keep the demon in it won't keep
curious little girls out which brings us
to this Annabelle's first a jailbreak to
atone for their accidental dealings with
the devil the Mullins generously invites
sister Charlotte's and s six orphans to
come live with them the house rules are
simple do your chores be polite and
don't open the evil closet yes
that evil closet stop what are you doing
horror predictably ensues from here as
the free at last evil spirit proceeds to
terrorize the household possessed Janus
and do away with both mr. and mrs.
Mullins eventually sister Charlotte
saves a day by trapping both the
possessed Janice and the doll in the
scripture closet and corn the cops but
when they show up the only thing in the
closet is the doll and the hole in the
wall where Janice presumably blasted
through let the kool-aid man and made
her escape demon for adoption now
occupying the body of an adorable child
and calling itself Annabelle the demon
makes its way to an orphanage and is
immediately adopted by the Higgins
family with whom it lives happily ever
after or at least until 1967 when we see
a grown up Annabelle return home and
brutalize her parents which causes a
ruckus awakes at the neighbors who are
of course the central characters of the
first stand-alone Annabelle movie roll
credits and the mission accomplished
you've just watched a terrifying origin
story that enjoys perfect continuity
with the rest of the conjuring universe
Annabelle explained you don't have to
have seen the first Annabelle to enjoy
the creation origin story but if you did
creation answer some important questions
about the events from the film for one
we can safely assume that Annabelle who
was really a possessed Janice didn't
take out her adoptive parents in a
cultist attempt to resurrect the RAM she
is the RAM so when Annabelle / Janice
officer parents slits her own throats
and bleeds into the dolls eyeball the
demon possessing her moves back into the
first vessel it ever occupied and sets
its sights on a new human target the RAM
clearly has a thing for kids which may
explain why it's so drawn to this
porcelain body where a creepy doll goes
children are sure to follow
the bigger picture let's not forget that
Annabelle creation is part of the larger
universe of the conjuring films and
here's where things get interesting
because there's not just one evil entity
in this movie the demon we're calling
the round was still imprisoned inside
the doll in the closet when Janice had
her first few brushes with the
supernatural which means there must be
another demon in the Mullins house which
one will give you a hint if it grabs you
like an evil nun and dresses like an
evil nun and pushes littlewiggle
chair-bound
children into barns like an evil nun
it's probably an evil freakin nun also
known as Vala
the demonic entity whose sister act will
headline the next film in the franchise
it's not clear yet whether the nun is
specifically connected to the RAM that
possesses the Annabelle doll or whether
she would have showed up to help any
evil spirit that had gotten herself
trapped in a closet but with a creepy
post-credit scene in creation that acts
as a teaser for the nun standalone film
we can be sure that in the tangled web
of the conjuring universe everything is
connected
please from the start
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know your love tea
[Music]